mein name ist mohammed war weil ich
komme aus kenia lebe seit 16 jahren in
der schweiz bin in berlin mit einer
schweizerin verheiratet und pendler
täglich zur arbeit nach zürich so
unbeachtet komme ich normalerweise nicht
an einem polizisten vorbei weil
regelmäßig werden oder dich
herausgepickt und kontrolliert dagegen
wehre ich mich nun ich lese ein buch
sie kommen direkt zu mehr kann ich nicht
weiter essen denn mein kopf dreht
einfach um alle leuten sein
und es bestärkt diese bilder ja klar
vielleicht ist der illegale rechte
kriminelle
vielleicht reißt er ohne
ohne billet es ist nicht nur ein
niedriger aber es ist eine psychische
gewalt wenn polizei mich wegen meiner
hautfarbe als kriminell sein denn es ist
wirklich zeit ihre schublade denken
aufzuräumen
ich habe islamwissenschaften und
friedensforschung studiert nun arbeite
ich an der eth als dokumentarist in der
bibliothek die arbeit mache ich gern
besonders gefällt mir hier die
internationale atmosphäre
ich bin akzeptiert hier beim arbeiten
ich kann nichts beklagen und innerhalb
meine freunde genauso es ist nur ein
kleiner teil
aber es ist wichtig weil es geht um
strukturelle rassismus alle meine
kollegen haben schon diese kontrolle
erlebt ohne verdacht alle paar jetzt
haben angefangen sich schick so
bekleidet mit krawatten und so einer hat
mir seinen trick verraten
er schützt sich in der öffentlichkeit
mit offizieller arbeitskleidung
er hat gesagt ja er hat immer diese
kontrolle erlebt ist er angefangen es
diese posse zu tragen
tyler risikos buch zur situation der
schwarzen in den usa hat mich sehr
beeindruckt
natürlich hat die schweiz eine andere
vorgeschichte
aber es gibt eben auch hier racial
profiling den verdacht rein aufgrund der
hautfarbe
ich habe zwei theaterstücke zum thema
verfasst und erreiche so mehr als wenn
ich darüber spreche dass wegen ich mache
ich diese theater ich finde es eine gute
art man zeigt leute sehen was ist
passiert
ich weiß noch zwei freund hat mir gesagt
du hast mir immer wieder erzählt von
deiner erfahrung aber erst jetzt
begreife ich was das heißt und so
die polizisten die mich hier als
kontrollieren sagen zeigt einfach deinen
ausweis dann hast du ruhe
aber wirklich ruhe habe ich erst wenn
sich ihr bewusstsein verändert und dazu
braucht es mehr sensibilisierung in der
ausbildung
71 vielleicht ja aber es gibt mehr viel
mehr so machen weil meine erfahrung ist
dass jedes heute monat werde ich
kontrolliert und machen mit die gleichen
leute die mich schon und poliert habe
deshalb verweigere ich jetzt die
auskunft bei einer ungerechtfertigten
kontrolle
ein ziviler ungehorsam im sinne des
großen deutschen dramatikers bertolt
brecht was ist muss es unrecht
und wenn recht zu unrecht wird wird
widerstand zur pflicht